well I want us to graph and then I want
to solve this inequality on the basis of
the graph in fact in fact sometimes
it'll say hints if you're lucky it'll
say hints or otherwise which means that
even if you look at something like this
and you're like gross I hate graphing
stuff it takes me forever I'm not very
good at it
hence what otherwise means you can still
solve this algebraically it's just very
awkward okay so I'm going to encourage
you I'm like we're going to do right now
to invest the time to graph because
definitely into unit you can't get away
from an extension one eval okay so first
let's draw up a Cartesian plane and what
I like to do what I think about is you
sort of add features of the graph onto
your Cartesian plane until you've got so
many features that there's only one
graph that can possibly fit all of the
features that you've got okay the guy
that I've given you before still applies
for something like this but it's quite
simple so in fact you'll find we don't
even need to go through all of these
steps before we've got enough of a
picture to know what the graph looks
like so what does F stand for f stands
for factorized in this case there's not
much to do and in two unit you will
frequently get graphs that are so simple
there's not really any factorizing
required but the principle helps you
with tougher questions the next question
is asymptotes now you guys know there
are two categories in asymptotes one
comes from the denominator
what kind of asymptotes do we get from
the denominator yeah vertical ones right
so what we want vertical asymptotes
vertical asymptotes occur when the
denominator is zero because that blows
up the equation right so if I say X plus
five equals zero all right you get a
vertical asymptote because it's outside
the domain I've just rearranged I change
and make X the subject so x equals
negative five is where I'm gonna find my
vertical asymptotes so I'm gonna draw
that in over here on the left hand side
x equals negative five cool that's not
the only kind of asymptotes is not just
vertical ones there's horizontal ones as
well right and later on the course
you'll encounter
horizontal asymptotes that are offered
an angle we call them oblique ones will
come to them a bit later into unit
you'll get these though a horizontal
asymptote is not about the denominator
on its own so that's the whole function
and what it does at the opposite ends of
the graph like it negative infinity and
positive infinity okay so I'm not sure
if you remember this but it's worth
revising there are two easy ways
actually is more than two but there are
two pretty straightforward ways to find
this okay
the first is get your calculator out
grab your calculator and then just test
out really big negative values or really
being positive values of X so for
example you could test x equals a
thousand right if x equals a thousand
then y will equal what's on the
numerator weight numerator 999 and your
denominator will be a thousand and five
now you can get your calculator to turn
it into a decimal if you like but
clearly that's close to one right you
also want to test the other side just so
you make sure you know what's going on
if you test x equals negative a thousand
so I've gone to this end right negative
then Y is going to be equal to let's
have a look negative a thousand and one
divided by which if you notice this two
as a double negative so it's just this
your calculator will also help you see
in fact I'm gonna ask you guys to help
me here can you give me the decimal
values for these guys just give me a
couple of decimal places
what's this 0.99 three yeah that'll be
dot dot dot and what about this one
what's accessible
cool dot-dot-dot okay now the only
reason why I point this out is because
you can't work this out without the
calculator but you see this is just
below one and this is just above so
that's going to be helpful when I draw
this thing okay so I've already decided
that I've got a vertical asymptote now I
know there's also a horizontal asymptote
it's going to be x equals one so I'm
just going to draw that in I did say
though that there's two pretty
straightforward y equals one
- pretty straightforward ways to work
this out if you don't want to if this
looks a bit in elegant and blunt
instrument to you like I'm just testing
values and the other thing you can do is
take your function and divide the top
and the bottom by the highest power of X
let me say that again divided by highest
power of X so if for instance you had X
Squared's on the top and the bottom
you'd divide by x squared in this case
the highest power of X is just it's just
X so when I do that I'm going to get x
over X minus 1 over X divided by X over
X plus 5 over X yeah that makes sense
now remember I said I'm interested in
the extremities right the far off spot
so I'm gonna use my limit notation to
indicate that as X approaches infinity
what happens to this thing well it's
going to be X approaches infinity these
x over X's are just wait hold on x over
X's are just 1 but these guys here yeah
they're gonna get tidy because it's 1
over some ridiculously large number this
guy over here is 5 over a ridiculously
large number but because it's
ridiculously large he doesn't care the 5
just sort of vanishes away ok so you can
see here this is going to become 1 minus
0 on 1 plus 0 so those those terms
they're insignificant and just like we
got before we're approaching 1 ok ok
do you mean like this the ridiculously
large number is anything our life so I
put it in a thousand because that's
large you can put in a million or ten
million if you want it just becomes a
bit silly and pointless because you're
already getting this behavior very
obviously right for this one here so
I've I've test out as X approaches
infinity right so therefore these things
are gonna clearly vanish
okay now by the way I did say I'm with
you this whole time rock was gonna come
in yourself finish this because I'm
almost there and then we'll let them
come in and do their thing and then
we'll come back okay if you guys want to
alright umm factorized I've got
asymptotes i stands for intercepts very
good so you guys can quickly tell me
when x equals zero when x equals zero
watch what happens
you just get left with negative 1 over 5
so i'll put that guy there and when y
equals zero with y equals zero that just
means the numerator has to be zero right
if the numerator zero the whole thing is
zero do you agree so then the x value
that gives that is x equals one keep in
mind this is negative 5 or a distance of
5 so i need to make sure my scales
somewhat consistent so i'm gonna put one
about there i'd say okay now if you
wanted to you could then go and do
regions but it's it's fairly
straightforward when you have a look at
this that it's going to go from positive
because you had two positive to negative
factors then down to negative then to
positive you can draw that in if you
like but this is so simple and you can
see for example you got a pass through
here you've got to go toward but just
below this asymptote so it's going to
look like i'm gonna have to do this the
kind of thing do you see that so here we
go like so and over here remember it
said we're going to end up just above
that y equals 1 line so that's why it
doesn't like sneak down underneath and
that's it that is the shape ok ok yeah
lastly
less than or equal to five okay what I
would do here
if it says hence if it says hence I'm
just going to put in five onto this
graph well would 5 be well there's 1 2 3
4 5
sorry my scales not great there's y
equals 5 so what I want is which parts
of this graph are less than or equal to
this blue line okay good
so you can see see this guy over here
this guy is fine from here and you
notice I put a on a filled circle
because the boundary is included so from
here all the way down here that's all
good right so I need to know what that
x-value is that corresponds to that I'll
come back to him in a minute what about
this branch how much of this is ok the
whole lot is okay everything here is
below the blue line okay so therefore I
can find this value and say to the left
of that and then I could say to the
right of this all of that is ok as well
let's see how far we can get let's find
this value when is it when is the graph
actually intersecting at five so what
I'm gonna have to do is say X minus 1 on
X plus 5 this graph hits 5 at a certain
point it equals 5 that's the boundary
right so therefore I can say X minus 1
is 5 X plus 25 yeah so therefore let's
see for X is equal to subtract 25 now
you're 26
so X looks like it's going to be
negative yeah
13 on - okay does that fit with the
information I already know look it's
just to the left of negative 5
looks pretty bang on to me okay so I can
say from there for the inequality X is
going to be less than or equal to
negative 6 and 1/2 now what about the
other side so it starts from negative 5
it goes all the way to the right okay
now last word of caution see how this
inequality includes the boundary right
so that's why this one includes the
boundary however this one
does not include the boundary why not
everything else has boundaries it never
actually gets to negative five does it
that's why this asymptotes here that's
why the graph helps us see that